I am about to cross a road and here is
something you might not know in Britain
there are special crossings for horses
not kidding because one I'm on
inspecting known as a Riedel way to
footpath the horses and riders can use
as well so here we have a special button
ads what they're as well since you
already mounted on your horse and a
special staging area there I'm currently
standing in in which horses can wait
before the lights change and they are
able to cross the road that way and here
is the best part the best part is the
Negev because in Britain we have Pelican
crossings pedestrian bike control
they're the normal ones and then they
came up with two can crushing because
they were for pedestrians and bikes so
two can cross there then they came up
with puffin crossings I can't remember
why they call that but they're the ones
with the special cameras and lights
write those up there that will track
pedestrians as they cross and not stop
the traffic any more than they have to
and them because all those are named
after flying things we have this which
is a Pegasus crossing and that is
something you might not know
you